Everything you own from your clothes to
your car to your wife or your husband is
going to forget you and move on and be
replaced the moment you die. That's why
Allah says
you are busy with the worldly affairs
until you visit the graves. Brothers and
sisters, masid Norway, the one that we
built is looking to another masid around
the area of Norway. Subhan Allah. Where
there's so many Muslims that do not have
somewhere to pray. This masjid is only
$500,000 and any donation that you give
will go towards your because when you
enter that grave, nobody's going to
remember you except Allah subhanaa tala.
So make it count brothers and sisters
and donate towards this message
inshallah a new project that's only
$500,000 and believe me if every single
one of us give £1, £10, £100, £1,000
that's going to be something you will
never regret on your makyama and
everything that you lose is going to
perish and go. but your deeds and your
Makyama are not. Donate to the link
inshallah. Let's get to the video.
To brothers and sisters and dear
friends, hope you guys are well,
inshallah. Um, so sisters, subhan Allah,
um, there was a video and I'll be honest
with you, uh, I'm on Andrew Tate's case.
Why I'm on his case? Because since I've
seen him attack Muslims, I realized to
myself, there's something deeply wrong
with this guy. And because I not
promoted him, but I spoke good of him
and assumed the best in him when he
first became a Muslim. Now, what he
said, a couple of words, just a couple
of seconds just unraveled everything for
us instantly. And personally, I can just
have only one small good assumption
about him. Only one little thing that's
left and that he's being blackmailed or
coerced. That's nothing else. Because
seeing how uncomfortable he was when
Sneaker was mentioning the whole Israel
thing, this clip I'm about to show you
guys is going to, you probably seen it,
be like, "Okay, it makes sense." Now,
let's go to the clip inshallah and see
what did he mean by that. Let's just go.
Like it is what it is. I understand how
these things get attached to my name.
It's very inconvenient for me. I have
Jewish business partners. I have tech
teams in Israel. I have things going on
and I get a mess from this crap, too. I
can argue that I was set up. I can argue
that Sneak wasn't thinking. I can argue
that they were just trying to chase
clicks. I could argue it was malicious
or not malicious. But truthfully, from
the bottom of my heart, truthfully, I'm
not here to beg sorry from anybody.
>> So guys, as you can see, these were
Patrick Pavid. absolute shells who were
bought by these dirt bags. He's sitting
with someone who has not done one video
for Palestinians. He sees them as
inhumane, like unhuman. They're not
human. Not a single post. And he's
sitting with them, Zionist bastards, the
scums. And then he goes, I've got Jewish
friends. That's fine. I've got Jewish
friends. I know people who are Jewish.
I've been I've been to uh synagogues.
Yes. With Aaron in Speaker's Corner.
I've visited uh them. when a innocent
Jewish man was attacked by a lun lunatic
Muslim. I done a video about it. So,
alhamdulillah, no problem with that at
all. Then he goes, he's got companies or
people who work for him in Israel.
Interesting. Interesting fall of events,
isn't it? Um, subhan Allah. So, looking
at this now, guys, there's two options.
The case against him. Yes. The case
against him, him being locked up. Yes. I
think he was told clearly and we know
Mos's techniques. It's the honey trap.
That's one. Uh, number two, it's what
they know things about you like the
Epstein islands. Yes. Um, I forgot her
name. Maxwell, Robert Maxwell, uh, uh,
his his daughter, all connected to Mosad
agent individuals. Even Tommy Robinson,
he said, "I'm proudly in Mosad." But
that agent, Mosad had that island. Yes.
Epstein, they were paying this guy to
have that island to blackmail and have a
pedophile ring, a pedophile island, a
pedo island where they would use this to
blackmail people. And I believe the only
good assumption I can have is Andrew. Um
they had dirt on him and they said
listen this will lock you up. You want
to be locked up forever? You know you
was in prison. Remember how long you was
in prison? Do you want your life to end
like that? Is this how you want your
life to be? Top G, top G rotting in for
what? For your belief. You can still
have your belief. I this what I believe
this what happened personally. Yeah. You
still have your be a Muslim. No problem.
Be a good Muslim. Be a good Muslim and
just talk about whatever is for that
matter. Don't get involved in politics.
Yes. Before you can see what he was
talking about Hamas or like Palestine
etc. Whatever is saying good or bad,
whatever is for that matter. Subhan
Allah. has shifted. He is there. Subhan
Allah. And he says, "What? Can you
imagine that the a Muslim country is
carrying out an active genocide towards
the Christians or the Jews?" And I say,
"Yeah, you know, my editing team, they
are in uh for let's suppose for example,
Morocco." Yes, Morocco is committing a
genocide against the Jews or the
Christians. And I go, "Yeah, I've got
active team members in Morocco."
There'll be up uproar. This shows guys
subhan Allah that they have either
bought him out, blackmailed him or even
worse which is be your worst assumption
he has done this willingly. Why? Because
and he already has money but he has no
more cuz his goals and objectives are
not in the hereafter. He has said you
know what yeah you know I have no choice
but to work with these guys and you
could have tech bro you could have tech
companies or partners working for you
all around the globe. Where do you go?
Where do you have to mention Israel? cut
off all the entire globe. The entire
globe. He had to mention Israel. Guys,
just think about it for a second. Either
that was told to him to say that or
number two, he has dropped so low out of
the entire world's 9 billion population,
he went to Israel. And that speaks a
lot. And I think the matter is clear in
this matter. If it is that he was
coerced, again, I'm so sorry. Like I
mean, I don't want to speak big, but I
would never want to. Whatever happens, I
wouldn't want to do that.
It shows you the reality of things,
brothers and sisters. Those who stand up
to truth, they have to sacrifice this
life and maybe he was not willing to do
that. And this is probably going to be
the last video about him entirely
because now that this come out, there's
nothing else needs to be said. May Allah
subhana wa tala guide us and guide him.
Everything you own from your clothes to
your car to your wife or your husband is
going to forget you and move on and be
replaced the moment you die. That's what
Allah says.
You are busy with the worldly affairs
until you visit the graves. Brothers and
sisters, masid Norway, the one that we
built is looking to another masid around
the area of Norway. Subhan Allah. Where
there's so many Muslims that do not have
somewhere to pray. This masjid is only
$500,000. And any donation that you give
will go towards your because when you
enter that grave, nobody's going to
remember you except Allah subhana wa
tala. So make it count, brothers and
sisters, and donate towards this message
inshallah a new project that's only
$500,000. And believe me, if every
single one of us give one pound,
£10,100, £1,000, that's going to be
something you will never regret on your
makama. And everything that you lose is
going to perish and go. But your deeds
and your makyama are not. Donate to the
link inshallah. Let's get to the video.